the 2010's were a decade of slicing
dicing and monstrous thrills and horror
fans were treated to a whole host of
legitimately terrifying films from
satanic thrillers to psychological
suspense flicks these were the best
horror movies of the last decade one of
Darren Aronofsky's best films Black Swan
is a fever dream that follows Nina a
solid core ballerina in an esteemed New
York ballet company with dreams of one
day dancing the lead when she finally
does get her big break Nina begins to
crumble under the pressure to embody
perfection and her already tenuous grasp
on reality slips from her grip entirely
and that's when things start to get a
little bit freaky in reference to Nina's
penchant for self-harm as well as the
film's body horror The Guardian writes
fantastically deranged at all times
Darren Aronofsky's ballet psycho
melodrama is a glittering cackling
outrageously pickable scalloped fill in
a rare event for a horror movie Black
Swan went on to sweep during award
season and lead actress Natalie Portman
walked away with the Oscar BAFTA Critics
Choice and SAG Award wins for her
nuanced betrayal of a mentally ill
artist teetering on the brink of sanity
and tell her eventual and terrifying
fall arguably one of the most self-aware
horror movies since Wes Craven's scream
The Cabin in the Woods follows a group
of gorgeous youngsters and their one
goofy stoner friend during a long
weekend at a cabin in the woods owned by
a distant relative but as the Sydney
Morning Herald's Jake Wilson put it it
sounds like the oldest horror story in
the book but from the first scene of the
cabin in the woods it's clear that
director Drew Goddard and his co-writer
Joss Whedon are bent on turning the
formula upside down a hair dye dumb
blonde very artistic things get
incredibly bloody and funny and the
movie works as a genuine horror flick a
comedy and a fantastic critique of the
slasher genre exquisite Terra's Neleus
Cargill wrote much will be lost on those
less accustomed to the classic horror
film by that's not to say it won't be
enjoyable in fact it's a perfect
introduction to the genre accessible
enough to real folk in when twin
brothers Elias and Lucas's mother come
home to their quiet lake house after
cosmetic surgery on her face the boys
begin to suspect this woman isn't
actually who she says she is at all good
night mommy quickly takes a darkened
test spiral into madness as the boys
test the woman in horrifying ways trying
to prove that she is or isn't their
mother needless to say this movie is
pretty rough as lanique a cruise of the
Atlantic writes beneath it all is the
nagging and heartbreaking feeling that
these boys have lost their protector
that vulnerability combined with their
isolation their confusion can be harder
to stomach than some of the more graphic
scenes Northshore news is julie crawford
agrees saying rip straight from the
pages of your therapists notebook good
night mommy is a thoroughly terrifying
fairy tale with a killer twist after one
of the most terrifying opening scenes in
horror history were introduced to Jay a
young girl who has an uncomfortable
romantic tryst with a dude named Hugh
the affair results in Jay becoming the
vehicle for a monstrous creature that
will kill her and the person had haunted
before her if she doesn't pass it on to
someone else through intimate contact
this shape can only be seen by the
person infected making this gritty film
not just about relationship paranoia but
also the old-fashioned kind of paranoia
where Jay questions are very hold on her
sanity this thing it's gonna follow you
further it follows this backdrop of a
crumbling Detroit adds yet another level
of social commentary about cultural
disintegration along with mental and
physical degradation BuzzFeed's Alison
Wilmore asks it's a testament to how
scary a movie it follows is that four
days after watching it you walk around
thinking of survival plants should you
hide stay on the move forever past the
haunting onto someone else is there a
third option not get infected at all
let's pick that one instead
Betty Alvarez is taught invasion horror
with a twist
don't breathe features three young
thieves who decide to rob a blind man
rumored to keep hundreds of thousands of
dollars in cash in his house little do
these inept robbers know the home owner
is ex-military and as blindness hasn't
affected his physical prowess or
tactical abilities in any way shape or
form The New Yorker writes the suspense
is built as carefully as it is in a good
John Carpenter movie alvarez uses the
camera like a stealth weapon exploring
dark corners in hidden areas of the
house with devilish glee father son holy
gore agrees saying there's so much to
enjoy even when we're taken down the
rabbit hole of depravity after the
secrets of the house are finally
revealed the premise of train to Busan
is pretty
straightforward my father and his
estranged young daughter get on the
train from Seoul to Busan where they
come to find out a zombie virus has been
unleashed but this is more than just a
zombie movie even for all its core and
violent action as the humans struggle to
survive
written and directed by young sang-ho
the story is a character study of a man
and his fractured relationship with his
daughter and ex-wife it also manages to
create three-dimensional characters
quickly within the other humans battling
for and mostly losing their lives which
only makes the story even more wrenching
Roger Ebert calms Brian Tallarico rapes
the most purely entertaining zombie
belman some time finding echoes of
George Romero's and Danny Boyle's work
but delivering something unique for an
era in which kindness to others seems
more essential than ever in rural New
England decades before the Salem witch
trials and subsequent panic that
continues to haunt the region a farmer
and his family are forced to relocate to
an even more remote area after
unwarranted suspicions about them
threatens full-out banishment by the
church soon enough the community's
distrust of the family seems to be
justified as it turns out there really
is something evil lurking in the forest
a grim installment of the folklore
sub-genre the witch is a truly scary
film that deals with far more than just
the devil and according to The Dispatch
it's masterful blending of the sacred
and the blasphemous makes it not just a
great horror film but perhaps the first
true horror masterpiece of the new
century and as the Guardians Benjamin
Lee says like any outstanding horror
film it's true impact only reveals
itself once the credits have rolled and
it stays buried under your skin breaking
through every now and then to remind you
of its insidious power while Jordan
peels seminal get out was far from the
first important installment to black
horror it was one of the first to garner
mainstream attention that hasn't abated
even slightly in the years since its
release this quietly menacing horror
movie centers on a young black man as he
discovers the nefarious nature of his
white girlfriends family when he shows
up at their secluded home get out isn't
just a parable about the underlying
racism that seeps into all corners of
American society including supposedly
progressive and liberal circles by the
way I I would have voted for Obama for a
third term if I could best president in
my lifetime hands-down it's also a
scathing indictment of modern-day
slavery as pertains to the
commodification of black bodies in
America in particular for Cosmopolitan
Kendra James writes and using both
realities in his movie peel brings get
out to a higher level of for at least
for any person of color in the audience
we're all keenly aware of how possible
it is
Oh teacups allowed while watching this
one though Trey Edward Schultz his
sophomore feature it comes at night
takes place in a post-apocalyptic world
but don't expect a film like zombie land
or Mad Max fury road instead of zany
laughs or wild action this is a grim and
atmospheric horror drama that features a
family doing its best to survive the end
days after a deadly disease wipes out
most of the world here paranoia is as
contagious as the deadly infection
and the surviving family living in a
remote cabin does what they need to do
in order to survive no matter what the
film features powerhouse performances
from its small cast and as Karl De Los
Santos of smash cut reviews notes this
is a morality play at its finest there
are no heroes and no villains there are
simply humans and house even though Andy
mooska DS adaptation of Stephen King's
killer Klown opus it diverges wildly
from the book in some problematic ways
that didn't stop the movie from becoming
the highest-grossing horror film of all
time after all in spite of its
differences the film is pretty awesome
it follows seven youngsters who call
themselves the losers Club as they
navigate not only the perils of
childhood trauma school bullies and
abusive parents but also a
shape-shifting alien monster named penny
wise who eats children and has moved the
seven losers to the top of his dinner
list dying to film while fans of the
still scary 1998 miniseries were unsure
how bill skarsgård could take on Tim
Curry psychotic performance as the
murderous penny wise scars guards
old-world Europeans spin on the
character has become one of the most
terrifying monsters puts a screen
cultured vultures rights it provides a
worthy adaptation of one of Kings best
works it's scary as all hell but has
enough heart to keep even the most poor
adverse audiences engaged after the
death of her overbearing mother Annie
Graham's grief and anger began to spiral
out of control and re Esther's debut
film hereditary it doesn't help matters
any that a relationship with her son
Peter and her daughter Charlie aren't
exactly the best and it's that rage and
depression that prevents her from
noticing that something is very very
wrong with her kids until it's far too
late and as the family dynamic begins to
unravel and he begins to realize there
might be supernatural forces at play the
result is a movie that's almost too
disturbing to finish about this
atmospheric film Newsweek writes
hereditary feels like an endless drawing
out of that queasy shocking falling
dream sensation as the ground beneath
the Graham family and the fewer crumbles
Tony Colette's nuanced and
three-dimensional performance of a
mother past the edge in particular
received accolade upon accolade Chicago
Reader calls her quotes flawless and the
x UK writes
it's an astonishing performance from
colette a disorienting cocktail of
humane hurtful and hysterical in a
surprising twist worthy of a horror
movie itself the office of lawmen
comedian John Krasinski wrote directed
and starred in the family apocalypse
horror drama a quiet place alongside his
wife Emily Blunt in the film the Abbott
family is doing their best to survive in
a world that's been ravaged by aliens
that kill anything that makes a sound
the film opens with the grotesque
snatching of one of the Abbott children
and it eventually beers into body horror
territory as blunts Evelyn gets pregnant
slate says of the film there are moments
when the movie takes us firmly by the
hand and escorts us down a darkened path
and they lead to one of the most
profound of communal pleasures the sound
of a movie audience screaming is one in
a movie filled with jump scares that
it's cast can't vocalize the only quiet
place is on screen one of the few global
truths women are taught is to avoid
walking alone at night whenever possible
Anna Liliana for takes that truth and
spins it on its head and a girl walks
home alone at nights with her shudder
and Chuck's wearing skateboard riding
antihero the girl she walks whenever and
wherever she wants because she's a
vampire
the film's logline the first Iranian
vampire Western only partly encompasses
the genre bending magic of the film
making it both as iconic as original
vampire stories like Nosferatu while
simultaneously reinventing vampire
movies altogether Alex Dolby of dog and
wolf raped it has visual echoes of early
Jarmusch and Lynch it's stunning to look
at slow paced Moody and ponte an
original feminist reinterpretation of
vampire mythology and it's gender
politics check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]